a single day that goes by where somebody
doesn't private messages and ask us hey
what happened what did you do to make
the video the life of an entrepreneur 90
seconds how did that video get 10
million views within the first five six
seven days and I think today Mario it
said it said twenty four million views
as of today what's today's date
today is February 10th and a video and
live on October 31st
how did that happen so I decided instead
of given you know bits and you know
answers here and back let's just put a
video together to explain to you
step-by-step on exactly what we did for
this video to go viral and I'll
Wikipedia if you look online on
Wikipedia Wikipedia tells you the word
viral video what what is considered
viral viral is considered something that
gets five million views within the first
three to seven days a lot of people
think a hundred thousand views as viral
or fifty thousand views as viral viral
is when something gets into the five
million Plus range not within two years
but five million within a twenty to a
seven day period so let's talk about
that today what happened with us well
first I want to show you this story and
tell you the story and exactly what
happened with this video so mid-october
our YouTube channels been around for a
couple years now we probably have two
hundred twenty videos on YouTube we
decided to come up with a video telling
the stories roughly my story the life of
an entrepreneur ninety seconds we make
this video and we go live with it on
YouTube and on YouTube within the first
I think we go live on YouTube on Friday
night October thirtieth we go live a day
before Halloween and the first night it
gets 2500 views okay and then we decided
to directly upload the video to Facebook
and see how it responds on Facebook so I
upload a video on Facebook on Halloween
October 31st you see it on the screen
here I believe it's 3:13 p.m. Pacific
Standard Time
so I upload the video completely forget
about it I go take my kids my two year
on the for you see the pictures you
dusty con Dylan I get the kids we go to
go trick-or-treating okay and I'm with
the kids we're going around I'm trying
to carry this case matter of fact that
day I lost villain for like ten seconds
because he went to store and was hiding
under clothes
I couldn't find a kid and then we come
back I open a phone
Mario calls it says PayPal did you see
what happened with the video so what
happened with the video he said it got
fifteen thousand four hundred views in
the first four hours and so while it's
never happened before and then a couple
hours later I'm sitting down my dad you
know Saturday is a chance for he not to
go watch a movie Saturday let's go watch
a movie go to watch a movie together and
my dad says why it'll be interesting if
this thing's by fifty thousand views by
the time we're done watching a movie we
finished a movie I turn on the phone and
I look at the time two hundred and
twenty thousand views eight hours later
myth this has never ever happened before
and we don't really know if it's yet
going viral
great I come home kids are asleep I go
to sleep I wake up in the morning with
messages my phone is absolutely blowing
up our web sites shut down we're getting
emails left and right from people that
can't get on the website the video gets
two million views in less than 24 hours
and the next thing you know it gets five
million views less than 48 hours within
two days it gets five million views and
then we have people from a hundred and
fifty six different countries on the
website looking at all the other content
and and you know Philippines Malaysia
China Argentina Brazil Russia UK we're
getting private messages overnight was
twenty three thousand private messages
that was roughly sent to us and the next
thing you know it's at ten million views
fifteen million views twenty million
views and now twenty four million views
and this happened and people ask how
would it happen I'm going to share with
you twenty six points on how to make
your content go viral and let me preface
something before I go into this I did a
video a couple weeks ago the video was
titled how to choose the right mentor
not how to find the right mentor and
keep it it was titled how to choose the
right mentor the reason why I said
choose the right mentor people send me a
message and saying hey I'm thinking my
paying this guy $8,000 he's a social
media expert and I want him to mentor me
it's an eight thousand dollar package
should I do it or not you know this
other person's telling me if I go to his
event it's fifteen thousand dollars and
he's going to teach me all the social
media secrets he has on how he now has
this many
subscribers on YouTube you know hey this
other person I was watching his video
and he advertises a hundred thousand
dollars a month on YouTube and now he
has you know four hundred thousand fans
what do I do I want to learn from him
but I don't have 100 thousand dollars
what do I do
look everything I told you with this
video going viral this is how much money
we spent boosting the videos zero if you
look at the video you don't see a single
boost on the video now one penny was
advertised on this video that to me it's
a true video that goes viral so let's
talk about that the message I'm trying
to tell you is you know we're not social
media consultants you know hiring you
you hiring us to pay us twenty thousand
dollars so we run a financial firm
that's growing rapidly we had our
biggest percentage growth last year I'm
purely running the YouTube channel to
provide content because I'm absolutely
convinced the world is a better place if
we get more entrepreneurs around the
world that are self-sustaining who know
how to make their money on their own and
they create jobs for other people
they're happy because you're creating
value for the world and marriage is
better their families better they make
more money the economy that's better
taxes are lower freedom is higher that's
what I believe in so my challenge to you
is when I go through this you're going
to probably watch this video a few times
and I will offer a PDF at some part of
the video to get all the content here
where you can go log on and get the PDF
yourself and share it and learn it and
apply it to yourself to see maybe you
can produce the next viral video that
the world hears about and you inspire
people so let's get right into it now
before I get into the 26 steps what I
want to do first is I want to first talk
about you know the different types of
content that goes viral it's very
important for us to know this before I
get into my uh my 26 steps first ones
humor cats dogs pranks jokes I don't
know how many cat videos go viral right
I don't know how many dog videos go
viral I don't know how many of these
prank prank who's my favorite prank a
like fouseytube fouseytube and Vitaly
Zee TV or something like the vitaly z
DTV something like that fouseytube you
two are hilarious and I'll make one
wager with you you can never prank me
everybody's always try to prank me they
cannot prank me but I'll make a wager
with you guys
you can prank me but I love what
fouseytube and vitalyzdtv do they're
probably one of the best pranksters
online but that's one of the ways videos
go viral that's one the other one is
fights you see a two girls fighting goes
viral did you see this fight did you see
these two gangsters fighting did you see
this big guy get knocked up by this
small guy did you see this guy that was
being bullied and also he picks up the
kid body slams them 28 million views did
you see that fights making fun of
someone always does well there's a lot
of people that make fun of the president
it does well making fun of LeBron it
does well making fun of Kobe's turn
around whatever it is it does well right
controversy rebellion changed conflict
it as well matter of fact media makes
their money based on telling three types
of stories controversy changed conflict
that's how MSNBC Fox and CNN make their
money just remember that controversy
changed conflict they don't make money
telling good news they make money
telling bad news they make money finding
something negative about Donald Trump
Hillary Clinton you know President Obama
Romney pret people they say negative
things and it does well that's what
sells for them right be why is that you
may ask why because believe it or not
people are more curious about bad news
than good news I can't tell you how many
people are attracted to bad news than
good news they say bad news we share it
with eleven different people good news
we share with three different people
which tells you what it's a lot easier
for controversy and conflict to go viral
than something good to go viral but
let's continue fear goes viral end of
the world earthquake is going to happen
in California and palm bill is going to
be a beach that's exciting to some
people oh my goodness the big earthquake
is going to happen San Andreas Fault
there is aliens that are about to take
over Russia and China they're coming
right now
people are afraid they like that because
for whatever reasons like we like horror
movies right next one is creative
product commercials Mario loves it
what's your favorite one it's a Dollar
Shave Club this guy is like in love with
Dollar Shave Club you know with the guy
the way he does his stuff you know Old
Spice that's a good one with two of the
guys right there the one guy the
bodybuilder guy the guy a horse yeah and
then Pepsi did one with Jeff Gordon you
know if you haven't seen these they did
a very good job Pepsi did a great job
would you know Jeff Gordon Kyrie Irving
that everybody wanted to watch it was
just hilarious Carrie's dressed like
this old man in his 70s and he comes on
the floor and he just schools everyone
it's a great video people want to share
that sex they do very well not talking
porn I'm not talking porn because you
can't upload porn on YouTube all the
porn definitely goes viral it's just we
don't share it it's private viral that
people find out about but sex what I'm
talking about is a beautiful girl
talking about sex the good-looking guy
with a nice body because people are
always attracted to good-looking people
so sex does well trust a voice of reason
a voice of reason you trust although we
don't have a lot of those nowadays next
correcting an injustice connick Kony
2012 was about correcting an injustice I
think within within the first 5 days he
got 72 million views
within the first five days he was trying
to correct and injustice and if you
remember that one scene in the video
where the young boy is telling a story
about his brother where he says I want
to die because I want to see my brother
I miss him it's about 15 seconds I don't
care who you are any part of the world
if you watch it you're going to be
emotional
everybody was sharing that people change
your profile pictures on facebook to
Kony 2012 people join the movement and
then the person who started made a big
mistake within a week or two weeks and
then the entire think imploded
so last one what is the toughest type of
videos to make to go viral because
that's what I want to talk about today
I'm not talking about any of this stuff
you can do all this about if I was a 13
year old kid I would probably have my
own you know prank channel on YouTube is
what I would do if I was somebody if I
was 18 years old and all my life was all
about body building you see some of my
you know my entire life was all run
bodybuilding I probably do something
around bodybuilding but I'm talking
about value-based
I'm talking about stuff that you could
do that's pure value in the area of
business because the toughest type of
content to go viral is value education
ideas value education ideas
my entire mo of this message here is
disclaimer money not spent on boosting
zero dollars spent on boosting I'm not
talking about you boosting I'm talking
about zero dollars spent on that content
going viral and there's a formula for
which we'll talk about value education
and ideas now one one organization
that's done a phenomenal job with this
is TEDx TED Talks I mean everybody
watches TED Talks and there's a lot of
profound messages with videos that go
viral with TEDx or TED Talks and I think
they're probably at the top of the list
with that another one would be Khan
Academy I think Khan Academy is another
one that's done a phenomenal job with
getting people to go their students kids
they have I don't know how many million
subscribers on YouTube two and a half
million subscribers
Salamun Khan he's done a phenomenal job
educating the world which is basic
how-to videos and by the way there's
nothing entertaining about him it's
simply educational as what he is as he
shares his content with them so with
that being said let's get right into the
message let's get right into 26
different ways keys to making your
content go viral number one let's start
off with number one tell a story people
like to hear stories it is not a new
thing that's been around for thousands
of years parables stories tell it like a
movie as if I'm watching something if
you're telling the story when you're
writing write it in a way as if I am
feeling like I'm reading a story don't
write it in a way where a professional
writer that you learn back in school and
high school how to write write it as if
I'm sitting there now feeling your
emotions I'm feeling what you're going
through and as you're telling this story
there is a key to reminding me of a time
in my life that I relate to so you got
to connect with me there's got to be a
certain sort of connection when you're
telling your story with your content the
second one is knowing your audience
who's the audience that you're speaking
to is the audience you're speaking to
that you want to connect with is it
young what's on their mind if you want
to connect with a 16 year old it's a 16
you were thinking about you know he's in
school yeah that doesn't have a
boyfriend or a girlfriend or he does or
he just got broken up or he can make
get on the sports team or he is a guy
that's on the sports team he's playing
football or he hates the guy that's the
quarterback because all the girls want
to be with the quarterback got to think
like that person if your audience is a
22 year old graduate from college what
is he thinking about what are his fears
I can't land a job I posted 20 resumes
what am I going to do next my father
wants me to get my own place I don't
have the money my girl and I'm dating
with I got to take around she's got this
place she's working on us she's got a
job and she's making 60 grand I don't
have anything yet her father thinks I'm
a bum you gotta understand your audience
that you're trying to connect with so
who is that audience you're trying to
connect with and by the way the more
specific your audience the more it goes
viral believe it or not the more
specific the more goes viral because
you're able to give birth to more loyal
followers the more general your audience
the less loyalty there is to your
audience we try to have the message be
too general to general of a message
you're not going to produce any loyal of
followers of yours three be specific of
an outcome clear message what is the
outcome of the video when we produce
this video a life of an entrepreneur 90
seconds the idea of it going viral
was the last thing we were thinking
about we weren't thinking about it going
viral the idea was for someone who's an
entrepreneur I remember door knockin I
remember how embarrassing it was when
people closed the door in my face at 21
years old when I got out of the military
I hated it I can stand sales I wanted to
quit every single flippin day about
being an entrepreneur so I wanted that
person who's out there running a
business to hear it and see it and feel
it and say that's me that's what I
wanted our message was for the
entrepreneur to know it's going to be
difficult it's going to be hard it's
going to be painful it's going to be
embarrassing people going to reject you
but if you stick around the glories
around the corner that's the outcome of
the message that we produce number four
be loved or hated but not like if you're
only liked your vanilla people like
vanilla ice cream people don't love
vanilla ice cream
people love chocolate cookie people love
you no give me some of the weird flavors
Mario of ice cream that they have some
of the ones that evil rocky wrote I mean
I hate rocky road but my wife
loves rocky road it's a love and hate
it's not vanilla we both like vanilla we
will settle for vanilla but we're not
going to settle for rocky road rocky
road is a lover hey B rocky road
do not be vanilla vanilla content me to
content to sum so many people try to
take something and just refurbish it
over and over and over again there's
nothing unique about it don't do me -
look the way I produce content people
ask a pad you have so much content how
do you produce it you don't watch me you
do well wait a minute I help you create
content but all your content is unique
yes it is but you helped me create
content how do I do that a conversation
with you question pops up I answer it
conversation with you I take a sheet of
paper and start writing it's late at
night 11:30 my wife is asleep and I'm
just writing writing writing got an
episode somebody asked me a question I
want to come up with a solution
do some research come up with a content
so the idea is just don't be a me -
don't try to be a like guy there's a lot
of people on this episode on this
channel that actually don't like my
content they don't like the fact that I
talk about free enterprise capitalism
entrepreneurship but there are those
that absolutely love it and it's an
entrepreneur living in African Zimbabwe
that all he does is follow this content
I'm trying to inspire him to become a
successful entrepreneur and become an
example to everybody around him to also
do that now that's the person I'm
speaking to but also the person that
hates me
you're also loyal follower to me the
person that likes me will watch it and
close it at any time I'm not talking to
the person that likes me neither should
you point number 5 is volume what do I
mean by volume explain to my what volume
is look my entire success story in
business is purely about volume he
reading books I used to there was a guy
that had read a hundred books and I was
so amazed by the fact that he could just
spit any quote from any book and then
all of a sudden I started reading five
books and I can't stand reading books 10
bucks 20 bucks 50 bucks 100 bucks then
when I got 200 books he stopped reading
he's more like at 120 books and we all
of a sudden started speaking the same
language then all of a sudden went to
200 books 300 books for men or books 500
books 600 700 800 1200 he then I all of
a sudden got wider and wider
and wider your brain elevates and it
vibrates at a whole different level
because I got white or volume
duplicatable you can't watch this and so
you can't do that your 13 year old
person watching this video out of
whatever part of the world you can
replicate that and you can rep replicate
a way earlier than me but it takes
discipline business volume I got into
financial services I don't have a market
my father works at a 99-cent store my
mother's back in Iran I'm a welfare kid
I lived in an apartment homeless for 30
days before I joined the Army in my
market I don't come from a family with a
last name of Ted Williams or you know
Kennedy or any of this stuff so I can't
go to my market and say hey I'm with
Morgan Stanley deal with it can you give
me two million dollars of your money
there was none of that went to a friend
I said what can you say be say 50 bucks
or money to American funds so what do I
do with that I can't compare with the
other guy volume deeper relationships
wider then you get better more
relationship more handshakes more places
you go to your YouTube channel or your
blog is the same exact way it's about
volume creating good content you cannot
just put a hundred videos and one night
and it's all regular videos and you're
hoping you're going to be an overnight
sensation it's not going to happen
you're looking at a product that took
from 1999 when I got out of the military
of reading books selling failing
producing creating content producing
value rejection to it then becoming what
it is today so it's not an overnight
thing that you're talking about you're
going to learn from a lot of my mistakes
you're going to save yourself ten years
but it takes effort create a lot of good
content again same message avoid me too
content if you don't have a blog right
now if you don't have YouTube channel
right now and you're producing your
first video of going viral the chances
of your first video going viral is slim
to none but you start producing more
than your your wider to have one of them
potentially go wider next go viral
next point over six phone number six
consistency you know consistency guy
says I want to be able to see man what
happened with you and they take the life
of the entrepreneur video and they do
the same exact type of a video matter of
fact I think to brands a mimic our
commercial life of an entrepreneur Mario
what were the two brands one was one was
the mini coop Mini Cooper
that identical commercial as us that
just came out a few weeks ago that talk
it's a current video yeah
it's called what label yourself define
labels and we did a video called label
yourself and the other ones Stefan curry
he did a commercial for it's called
everyday if you type in Stefan curry
everyday and then you go watch life of
an entrepreneur
it's verbatim pretty much identical
commercial but that video came out eight
weeks after ours went viral so you're
seeing that our contents getting
national attention from other people
watching what would produce it and it's
a compliment right it's a compliment but
it's consistency you've got to come out
with your content regularly you cannot
just put three videos out there and say
I'm gonna do it just like him a mine is
gonna go viral it's not not that your
audience doesn't think you're serious if
you put up three videos and you stop no
it's about I would rather have you do
one video every other week for three
years straight then you put up three
videos on the same day do one video
every week then go to two videos every
week or one video every other week but
the key is consistency 7 keep growing
your fan base keep growing your fan base
whenever your base is keep growing it
whether it's Facebook Twitter email
newsletter website YouTube keep growing
your fan base focus on the fan base that
you currently have 8 timing timing has a
lot to do with when you come out with
the content let me explain what I mean
by that many years ago when I started
the blog limitless came out the movie
limitless I don't even know one limiting
schema can you search to see one
limitless came up so the movie limitless
with Bradley Cooper comes out and I'm
watching the video and I'm telling
myself why is this pretty impressive
video and I'm big fan of Bradley Cooper
and I'm a big fan of DeNiro so both of
them in the same movie 2000 March March
8th mm so the night it comes out that
Friday night it comes out I go watch it
okay and at night I decide to write a
blog and I'm not a blogger I decide to
write a blog something to do with NZT
Einstein took NZT something like that
overnight then puck just went viral
overnight the blog went viral I'm
getting messages from people all over
the world
how can I get my hands on NZT and NZT
doesn't exist but it went viral so it's
pure accidental you see this works
because people wanted to find that the
same question where can I get my hands
on NZT there's a drug like that exist
another one was a blog I that Jordan
Kobe LeBron who's the greatest and it
was at the right time at the same time
that everybody was debating that next
you know that went viral so match match
calendars holidays right something that
hazard with that holiday MLK write an
article the night before prepared for
MLK let it go out it could go viral if
it is a good story movie opening if a
big Star Wars movie is coming out and
you time it perfectly and you write an
article because your big Star Wars guy
and you know all the history about Star
Wars who knows because potentially go
viral
Superbowl something related to the Super
Bowl Academy Awards like Super Bowl
these commercials which by the way 80%
of commercials that the Super Bowl were
absolutely pathetic it was embarrassing
even watching it we're sitting in our
room watching the Super Bowl at the
theater in our house and I'm just
watching commercial who's pathetic
commercials I think the best one I saw I
would say the Doritos commercial was a
good one I was hilarious with the kid
and following an embalmed she throws it
and she goes into labor another one that
was funny was I would say the Prius how
at the end the cap gets the Prius and he
can finally catch up there was a few
good while Mario said the monkey won he
remembers a monkey the monkey pitbull
dude
Mountain Dew commercial which I thought
it was terrible but he liked it he still
thinks about it 80% of it was terrible
80% of commercials were terrible but so
what if you write wrote something having
to do with the commercials right okay
Academy Awards is coming out so your
predictions on who you think is going to
win you know inauguration speech we're
about to have a president so you could
time it with inauguration the day the
inauguration is going to happen you have
an article that has to do with the last
five inauguration so something unique
about it it goes viral a debate
consistently right now there's a bunch
of political websites YouTube blog
vloggers that are doing very well
because all they're doing is writing
stuff about the current debate or fight
a big fight and when when the was a big
fight Mayweather against Pacquiao I go
meet with Pacquiao I think the day
before the fight
day before the fight or a week before
the fight I would pack here friend of
mine Dudley introduces me to a ah
we go over there now meeting him and
then the next week the fight takes place
and it ends up becoming the worst fight
of all time probably the worst fight of
all time
with Pacquiao Mayweather you know how
many people did very well because they
were talking skin and when Mayweather is
gonna win here's my man here's what
people don't about so there's a certain
timing of when you come out with that
contact next 24 9 have influencers on
your side you won't have this right off
the bat but you will eventually if you
keep contributing now we have many
people that want to collaborate with us
and they reach out to us and we reach
out to some that we want to collaborate
with but have informs on on your side
think about it say for instance this is
you okay and you have 1,000 people that
follow your content okay this is Joe Joe
has 10 million people that follow his
content
well a retweet from Joe automatically
puts you at what 10 million 1,000
followers and an influencer is sharing
your content so how can you get this
influencer to want to share your content
for it to go viral well a friend of mine
Joe Brown who founded their the website
addicted to success which I believe it's
one of the best motivational websites
online he's done a phenomenal job I was
speaking to him and I said hey what
happened with your website he says
honestly I'll say how my website blew up
I said tell me he said one day I write
an article said 10 keys to why'd Wayne
Johnson is blowing up something like
that and he says we tweeted it out and
it was fine all of a sudden I saw Dwayne
Johnson the rock retweeted an article I
wrote about him and it went absolutely
bonkers
he said all over the world people
started coming to my website addicted to
success and next thing you know he's got
the best motivational website online his
Instagram account is phenomenal at the
content he creates he does great
material he produces but he had his own
big hit because an influencer Dwayne
Johnson retweeted a link to his website
and that article went viral
number 10 study human nature
what I mean by studying human nature
okay so Paul do me a favor let's put up
that picture on the screen there was a
study done here by your buzz some that
New York Times picked up and the study
was what are the most popular emotions
that we have okay what are the most
popular emotions that we have in the top
three emotions that we have you see it
if you're looking at the screen with the
diagram there musi are 25% which is not
necessarily oh that's so cute all is
about I'm amazed I can't believe what I
just saw wow this is an interesting
surprise fear it was it got people to to
to have that amazement feeling Oh number
two was laughter and number three was
amusement right and other but if you
look at all laughter and amusement what
does that say laughter isn't necessarily
number one human nature responds to all
as a popular emotion we like to be
spooked if you want to call it if you
ever seen the movie cocktails it's
probably a few more people have seen the
movie cocktails by Tom Cruise we watched
a movie a couple hundred times when I
was in the army there's a scene where
the girl says I bet I could spook you
and he says you can never spook me yes I
can spook you how do I spook you we're
having twins I'm spooked you want to
spook people and the top emotion for
human beings that's all so how do you
create content for somebody to say this
about them having that feeling right and
a lot of times you'll see people that'll
say you know what was the reason why
someone goes viral and what was the
reason why someone reads an article New
York Times at an article where they
interview 2,500 people to determine the
primary reasons why they shared a story
online look what they said 2500 people
Paul let's put the link out there as
well for them to have it number one to
bring valuable and entertaining content
to go together
listen number one to bring valuable and
entertaining content together hence we
call our channel on YouTube value
tainment value and entertainment
together with this article came out
recently we made our channel long time
ago just so happens we got
we named the channel value 10 next to
define themselves to others give people
a better sense of who they are ok 3 to
grow and nourish relationships they
connected with others for for
self-fulfillment to feel more involved
in the world than 5 to get the word
about on causes they care about that's a
study New York Times that on 2500
different people why they shared
specific content maybe there is
something there for us to be thinking
about so that's one of the reasons why I
say study human nature you got to study
human nature you got to study and read
the books about what human nature thinks
about how they like to be communicated
with that's a product that's
never-ending it's something that we're
going to be studying for the rest of our
lives when you sit at a restaurant
sometimes watch people I like to sit out
restaurants and watch out some people
are talking to each other reactions
people's facial expressions says a lot
what is that person thinking about many
times I'll settle my wife and I said
what do you think they're thinking about
right now what do you think is on that
guy's mind how do you think the waitress
is feeling I'm curious about human
beings I'm curious about how they think
I'm curious about why they feel the way
they feel I'm curious why all of a
sudden somebody got upset or happy or
annoyed or what happened to that be
curious about human nature because the
reality of it is your number one product
is human a human is wanting to follow
your content you are making a human
being be interested in you
point number I'll have a bigger net the
bigger your net is the more likelihood
you have of your content going viral see
what if that video would have gone viral
life of an entrepreneur that was my
first video how terrible for it to go
viral you know why I don't have a net so
after somebody watches that video that's
it there's nothing else there so what
are we going to see after that there
isn't 220 videos for them to go watch
there isn't any other content that
brings value to them they watch it I
have a big net bone everything a rising
tide does what that's what all ships
right so you want to make sure you have
a bigger net 12 try different outlets
don't just stick to one outlet Facebook
YouTube and Twitter Facebook YouTube and
Twitter member the video the life of an
entrepreneur didn't do what all YouTube
if you go on YouTube it only has 130
thousand views it didn't do very well on
YouTube it's only at 130
thousand views on YouTube now kid it all
of a sudden have some traction next year
two years have a million or two million
views yeah but it's not considered a
viral video but it is on Facebook so one
platform work the other platform didn't
work some videos we put on YouTube it
does incredibly well and it doesn't do
well on Facebook it's not on you to
determine which one's better it's on you
to put it on both platforms and let them
decide what's going to do better just
think about it some movies didn't do
well in the theater but they did very
well in DVD some of these did very well
a movie theater but they did terrible in
DVD it's not for you to determine that
it's for them to determine that some
movies do well on Netflix some movies do
well on Apple TV you're not going to be
able to figure that part out because
certain community is doing that all you
could do is wider net right so try
different outlets 13 don't be general
don't be general I talked about a little
bit earlier and I'm saying this twice
because it's that important to be
thinking about that don't be general
don't have a me to channel don't be like
everybody else don't have a topic that
you're talking about you know 75
different topics in life that don't have
to be connected to one thing choose one
subject take a sheet of paper it's very
simple take a sheet of paper and make a
list of things you like to talk about
okay make a list of things you like to
talk about to then take the same sheet
of paper and make a list of things
you're good at okay
then based on this ranked top three
which one are you the most passionate
about top three and which today are
you're the most expert about then find a
one and have your passion be linked to
the number one thing you're an expert in
make your content be about that talk
about those two things now you may sound
not very clear about what I want to do
my life and my content no prompt listen
go take the ultimate discovery
questionnaire on my website ultimate
self discovery questionnaire on the
website Patrick Madiba comp ah let's put
a link up here so they know exactly what
it looks like ultimate self discovery
questionnaire it's a free pdf sheet that
you'll get thirty thousand people have
taken this test around the world and if
you read some of the private messages I
get they're the most emotional private
messages I get on a person that had an
absolute breakthrough and they finally
figured out what they want to do with
lives and they're living in East Africa
which I'm being invited to go speak to
and they're living in Chile and they
live in El Salvador and they took their
self-discovery questionnaire but it
helps you get away from being general to
being specific linked to your passion
and skill set and it'll really also make
you be looser and comfortable with
yourself because you finally have belief
and confidence in you where you're okay
being you I think a lot of time when I
sit in with somebody mentoring and and I
talked to somebody I'm talking to and I
say listen why are you uncomfortable why
are you why are you uncomfortable let's
let's process some things together and
then we process some things together
next thing you know just today we were
we were sitting around our team in our
staff every month we have a book club in
just today one of the executives who's a
top executive of our firm opened up and
talked about how he feels right now and
he's making so much money right now and
he's at his best he's never been this
happens says the other day I'm in my
place in Dallas Texas and I'm walking
around and I said I passed him and I
said never been this happy before but I
remember him from you know five years
ago three years ago or 1012 years ago
why is he so happy today because he
finally has a certain level of
self-acceptance with them that he knows
for the rest of his life he's going to
live with this guy and it's okay what
take a self-discovery question you learn
more about yourself to help your message
not be any more general and be more
specific next point number fourteen
point number fourteen okay catchy title
verses a searchable title when I write
that because so many times we try to
come up with a catchy title and I think
a catchy title may be more effective
when you have a bigger following and I
think a searchable title is more
effective when you have a smaller
following let me explain what I mean so
the title of this video was life of an
entrepreneur in 90 seconds by the way on
YouTube the video was titled best
motivational video in 2015 and it didn't
do well well I changed it to Facebook
and I titled a life of an entrepreneur
90 seconds and it did well so mix up
your titles sometimes on different
platforms searchable title is how to
write a book
how to start a business people search
that on Google and boom you pop-up okay
how to get married how to do this how
whatever someone's going to search on
whatever you search it you got to think
about yourself when you get on Google
what do you search yourself that's how
you're thinking 72 success keys to
success in business keys to success in
marriage keys to success in health keeps
the success in investing people will
search that keys to say Keystone but
that that that keys to success in
investing that's a searchable title so
play with this smaller platform use more
searchable title bigger platform use
catchy types okay
2016 for number 16 this whole myth about
length of time or length of article I
think it's an absolute myth where people
say you know with the video you don't
need to make long videos because they
don't do well really okay I hired a
consultant and he kept telling me this
over and over and over and over and over
again so listen I don't agree and one
day we got into this big I said listen I
just absolutely disagree with you know
it doesn't do well and I said who said
this in the first place some social
media consultant they convinced somebody
paying $10,000 and then all of a sudden
everybody else wants to say mimic the
same thing he'd say because you wrote in
a book that doesn't make it true
I don't agree with that no it's not
right I said look why is it that Harry
Potter it's a long novel did so well so
you should write a book enough some 10
pages ago viral no way
it's BS no Harry Potter went viral Atlas
Shrugged went viral
you hobbit went viral yummy to tell you
how many books the Bible went viral
you know Dianetics went viral all these
books went viral there are so many books
that go by so why is that
why is that so you need to write no
don't believe the hype when these
experts give you this advice and they
sound so certain about it and people buy
it let me give you some research from
New York Times again little bit research
here they did a study and here's what
the study was they did a study finding
out how much words in an article causes
it to be sure the most okay let me see
if I have the exact numbers here yes I
do perfect so here's the average now
let's put it up sedate
see it they they show average going
through thousands of articles on how
many words in an article made it go
viral zero two thousand words it was
roughly 4000 K that it was shared with a
thousand to two thousand words is
roughly six thousand shares but two
thousand to three thousand words as nine
thousand shares why is that I thought it
was said that videos need to be short no
look here's what I believe it if Titanic
that's a three-hour movie can go viral
soak in your fifty two minute video okay
we go what do you think happens with
movies movies go viral
why do they go viral if a movie cannot
up watch movies we're like this I fall
asleep if I fall asleep
that's a terrible blog that's a terrible
YouTube channel you'll lost me but if
you captivate me for three hours
I'll watch your North and South was a
long series Godfather is long but it's
captivating don't subscribe to this myth
of your video needs to be longer your
blog needs to be short absolutely
disagree with it you can disagree with
me I may be completely wrong I may be
completely off on what I'm saying but I
have subscribed to this concept and I've
looked at both sides and it's just
worked in our favor it's 17 entertain
our channels call value tainment your
own value came in watching this you may
see this on youtube you may see this on
my website you may see this on Facebook
you may see this on Twitter if you go on
youtube and type in value 10 me where
the first ones to come up we produce the
channel and we call the value tainment
because we decided our being value and
entertainment together we did a video
last week with Mario and I was trying to
make a point of how how how to handle
chaos as an entrepreneur and and there
was a part where I explained an amateur
entrepreneur you know how they react to
it Paul why don't we just put a 1520
second clip and show what it looks like
here's what it looks like just look at
this so first one is first one is
amateurs amateurs tend to overreact
all day long cut the video all day
freakin long we asked you to do one
thing right you can't even move nothing
it doesn't matter we're doing a damn
video over here man what the cut the
damn video all day long he does this
crap something that's called
overreacting that's what you don't do
right people saw it and they said wait a
minute was that real did you really get
upset at him did that really take place
it doesn't matter whether I did or not
the point is the point was made and it
was entertaining people look tense oh my
goodness he almost fell he felt pretty
bad so entertain when you're doing your
videos as well or you're creating your
content as well let your personality be
seen in the Articles they're reading
about 18 call to action okay call to
action you know subscribe share this tag
and entrepreneur tag a millennial tag
somebody give me some sort of a call to
action that can make the content go
viral and be sure because the key is if
within the first 5 to 10 minutes there
isn't traction it's generally not going
to go viral
it is typically an immediate thing we
produce another another video that was
called um if you allow the world to let
you know what's a call it was called how
the world views entrepreneurs in 30
seconds okay we put the video up and
boom it did well but it only got 150,000
views it didn't go viral right why it's
because the first five minutes and then
it wasn't shared by the right
influencers it wasn't tagged enough
times and then it didn't go viral great
video put a lot of heart into it but it
didn't go viral right so you got to have
the right call to action there 19
accessibility make it easy for me to
find it and share it don't make it
difficult 17 different steps for me to
do this now it's got to be boom it
shirts the reason why videos Facebook is
competing with YouTube at a whole
different level because I can see the
video easier I can upload the video
easier I can share the video easier
YouTube's a little bit more difficult
but YouTube allows you to create a
searchable place where you and I go to
learn we don't go on Facebook to find
videos but Facebook allows videos to go
viral in a way YouTube probably doesn't
allow for it to go viral 20 be real and
genuine when you're when you're when
you're talking to people or you're you
know doing a video writing an article
just be real and be genuine don't act
like you're somebody else you know this
is how I am if you see me around me and
if you do business with me this is how I
am this is my personality I don't I
don't have an I don't have an you know
it's not an act so you know there used
to be town where you know this is what
this is how you talk them the best way
to do a video is just if you can speak
on video the way you have a cup of
coffee with your best friend you're at
best if I can watch you and I feel like
I'm talking to you 101 and it's just you
and I talking together that's the best
way to do any kind of a communication if
I read a blog and I feel like it's a
letter I got for my best friend those
are the best blogs those are the ones I
want to read if I read a blog and I read
it as if a you know professional
journalist wrote it from XYZ place I can
tell it's too much profession behind it
sometimes for me I'm not the biggest fan
of hiring people with tons of degrees
because they've already been diluted
into thinking a certain way
sometimes want some Street you know
experience that you're coming from the
school of hard knocks and you've won in
the streets and you haven't lost your
identity so be real and be genuine when
you're telling your stories 11:21 be
visual you know if you're telling a
story on an article I did an article
recently when I left California body was
asking me why did you leave California
so I did an article and I wrote it I
said dear California here's why I'm
leaving you a love letter to California
and Paul may have put the image up you
know what it looks like it was shared I
don't know how many how many thousands
of times and there were some images in
there there were some pictures in it
there was some stories in it there was
some things that I talked about in there
and people are visual in videos post
pictures in articles post images of what
it is people are visual 22 be vulnerable
show if you're her
schon I might say something at the end
here before we finish the video and
you'll see because you know the former
ability is not an act you can act you
know great actors when they saw he's
such a great actor in Hollywood or that
person such a great actor in Hollywood
saying Kevin Spacey Edward Norton you
know Johnny Depp or a Pacino or who else
give me some great actors Paul you're
you know a a Meryl Streep I forgot well
no what's the Titanic was a good-looking
guy keep the camp you want some of these
guys you know hearty oh my gosh
to me you know McAdams you got Rachel
McAdams you feel your emotion and again
you know you totally people you've never
seen The Notebook obviously we have
never seen Notebook ever before because
it's just not a masculine thing to do
right but anyways be vulnerable
don't try to be in a box and not show
any weaknesses these days about you know
you're trying to hide yourself those
days are done so don't don't hold back
from being vulnerable now I got to that
I held for the end and I'll explain
those two why I did that I'll explain
that here in a minute but let me give
you the other two points and I'll get to
the last one 23 it's very weird that
title on 23 is is I put don't try to go
viral I think that was probably the
biggest thing for us as we were not
trying to go viral
there wasn't an intention of the video
going viral the intention was to inspire
an entrepreneur out there that watches
this and says I'm not going to give up
today and that could lead to another 17
job so that could lead to him meeting
his dream girl and his kids they give
birth to three kids and his and her
three kids end up having the enough
environment and the right money and
platform to go to the right school and
one of the kids ends up becoming a
governor that makes the state the best
state ever and produces hundreds of
thousands of jobs and the other kid
becomes a doctor who goes out there and
comes out with the cure for cancer
that's the inspiration the inspiration
is for that video to connect with
somebody connect with a lonely
entrepreneur that
somewhere to want to do something about
it it wasn't to try to go viral the only
reason I'm producing this video I don't
want this video to be Oh he's bragging
about this video getting 24 million
views it's a it's a video we didn't make
a penny off this video this video
doesn't make me any better than you it's
just a pure video that inspired you to
want to share with other people that's
all it was it's you show me love by
having the content give value to you
where you say man you know I love is
content you're royalty is why we are
able to share this content with you
because if there was no loyalty there is
no value tainment right so you helped
validate what we're doing but don't try
to make your content go viral don't
don't make it that hey we hope this
thing goes right it's not going to go
viral it's almost like the desperate guy
that wants to date that girl that girl
is not just interested in the desperate
guy that that girl is interested in the
guy that is almost not interested in her
and then she says wow how come he's not
going googoo gaga over me like everybody
else is you know hey we you know so
here's how we know go viral know produce
good content and if it goes viral goes
viral point number 20 for a cup of
coffee mentality I wanna give credit to
chase in a stat my goodness Casey if you
ever see this man you're an absolute
stud on who you are the way you tell
stories minutes it's amazing Casey I
don't know how many videos he's got on
YouTube I want to say 50 100 200 I don't
know the exact number on what it is he's
got one point eight two million
subscribers or whatever it is the guy's
absolutely the guy's absolutely
phenomenal 435 videos 435 videos and
he's got 1.8 million subs 2.1 million
subs is what he's got Casey if you ever
see this man you're a total stud your
total stud I would be very interested in
doing something with him because that's
a professional storyteller out there on
what he does study somebody like him and
see how he tells a story in a story is
there it's not the most here's 17 steps
to do this now he's simply telling you a
story but you feel like it's just you
and Casey talking to each other man
you're very impressive on what you do so
cup of coffee mentality I want to be
able to hear the story from you as if
I'm having a cup of coffee now point 20
five on point number 26 and then I'll
wrap up 25 in order for your content to
go viral you do need luck yes we got
lucky we absolutely got lucky but I've
been seeing this all my life
my wife will tell you I always get lucky
cop pulls me over lets me go and you
know all of a sudden we go do something
and I win I get lucky oh you know pal
you always get lucky I really believe
that I really believe I'm the luckiest
man alive and I really believe I always
get lucky I really believe that so part
of being lucky is really believing that
you're gonna get lucky it's almost a
mentality but we did get lucky we didn't
do everything and study this protocol
and seventy-three steps on having your
content go viral where that that's no we
run a financial firm we don't run a
marketing firm we get asked by people
and come up don't say we'll give you a
hundred thousand dollars you know can
you help us out with our marketing cuz I
like the way you guys think etc etc we
don't have time for that we running a
financial services marketing
organization that's grown at a fifty six
percent rate annually this past we had
our biggest growth rate ever we're all
across the country you don't have time
for any of that stuff we produces
content for purely value because we want
to inspire other people to become
entrepreneurs and so there's a lot of
luck involved in it and then I'll say
the last one on what it is
the last one is magic now tell you what
magic is you know it's a a the magic
part is what you know you it's very
interesting what happens let me tell you
story on what took place the other day
Tigran good friend of mine sequence part
of our production team Tigran you don't
see Paul back there and Mario Paul's
probably the most incredible editor I
know he's phenomenal what he does I love
his mind Tigran is a great idea guy and
he's grown a lot over the years that
I've had a chance of mentoring him I'm
proud of where he's Anna I'm proud of
where he's going to go and what things
were going to be doing together and
Mario's a leader and Tigran and I were
having a conversation and we were
walking in all of us and he brought it
up and we're talking to says Pat you
know s'ti do you remember what happened
that morning before we shot the video
the life of an entrepreneur because we
started at
time Paul 5:00 a.m. 5:00 a.m. we started
at 5:00 a.m. we start at 5:00 a.m. and
we're in front of house and production
team is out there we have the cameras
all this stuff and we have a 10-man crew
and and all of a sudden you know I come
out and my wife text me and we're at six
o'clock we're about to start shooting at
around 6:15 because the sun's coming up
we have the perfect timing
I go inside to see my wife and my wife
is absolutely ballin I've never seen my
wife cry like that before and you know
as a husband you know you don't ever
want to see the woman you're married to
do mother of your children she's
absolutely in tears bawling and you know
what kind of a tear pain type of tear
like truly in a lot of pain
and I said baby what's going on baby and
she says you know my dad just passed
away this is at six o'clock we're about
to shoot my dad just passed away we have
to go to Arkansas I said you got to be
kidding me no my veg is passed on oh my
gosh what do you want to do what can we
do we have to go drop off the kids we
have this and we have to book and okay I
call my mom and we got to buy this and
government and just just pure emotions
she doesn't know how to control herself
this is her dad this is the man this is
the man she looked up to this is the
family she's in pain emotions and I come
out and I asked her I said hey you know
what do you want me to do babe
you want me to cancel this whole thing
what do you me to just no baby you got
to do what you got it and I got to go
drop off the kids but I get also figured
a second's we got a fly out to our
concern so great so I come out and we go
into the chute and Mario comes up to now
say Mario man you know
Jennifer's father just passed you got to
be kidding me no and then so 15 minutes
later these guys are the guys they're
just they're trying to do their job so
we start shooting so entire shoot were
shooting I am an absolute confused you
know energy pain my wife guilt all this
stuff come by
together and you know sometimes life
happens and it happens at the most
interesting times and most people said
oh you know when I watch the feeling and
I watch you know how you felt in a video
when you're holding the steering wheel
etc says certain scenes you know man you
really you really you know act it out or
whatever sitting most people don't have
any idea my wife's father died that day
the next week we're in Arkansas Hope
Arkansas for the funeral that following
week when hope Arkansas for the funeral
is what we had to go to and so sometimes
you know when you're when you're doing
what you're doing a life is happening to
you those are sometimes the most
important moments for you to write
something for you to record something
for you to put something on paper for
you to put something on video because
many years later you're going to see
then you're going to see the stories
behind the story that's being told you
know the stories behind everything
that's being told and look you know at
the end of the day the purpose of why
we're in the world is to inspire the
next generation yours mine's everybody's
I really believe we're here to inspire
the next generation I really believe
that one of my favorite songs of all
time by uh Whitney Houston is you know I
believe the children our future teach
them well and let them lead the way show
them all the beauty they possess inside
give them a sense of pride to make it
easier let the children's laughter
remind us of how we used to be I really
believe that I really believe that
because that was a kid at one point
looking for somebody to inspire me and I
really believe it's you and iris
responsibility to inspire others out
there so if you're creating this content
or whatever you're planning on doing
because you want to be a celebrity it
ain't going to go do much for it it's
it's going to have a short life soon
because people can tell but if you're
really going to take this content that
we share today and somehow someway you
apply to your business and I hope it
helps you and you go out there and get
this content to go around the world and
you make an impact from a place that you
truly want it to impact in another
person's life as someone do to you it's
almost like to pay forward concept I
think people gonna sense that that's um
people gonna feel it I think you're
gonna get a lot more loyal people that
are truly going to want to hear your
voice be heard maybe you're a better
writer your voice through writing be
heard
and next thing you know there's somebody
out there that watches your content who
you don't even know about you're
inspiring on a daily basis that's the
great thing about today's platform that
we have with social media we have the
opportunity to inject an inspiration and
hope in people from all over the world
so with that being said with that being
said here's what I have for you I
promise you initially that I was going
to have a PDF page for you to get all
the 26 points there's a link on the
bottom are you what are you going to put
it's going to be on the bottom look for
the description on the bottom click on
the link it'll take you to my website
it'll be everything I covered in PDF
format for you to print out and use as a
platform to help you produce your next
content that you're doing with the hopes
of one of your contents going out there
and possibly grabbing traction and going
viral for itself so click on the link go
get the PDF if you haven't subscribed to
this channel do so and if you got any
questions or comments about it do that
as well Mari am I missing anything
so if yeah that's right you got to
subscribe to the newsletter and when you
subscribe to the newsletter you'll have
the PDF for 26 keys on how to make your
content go viral it will be sent over to
you with that being said thanks for
watching and subscribe to the channel
comment with any questions and we'll see
you soon
take everybody
you